I am Greg a fellow rejects hi I'm Lisa
for the longest time mm-hmm I have not
watched a trailer called a dog's purpose
for the longest time people have been
asking me for weeks and I don't know
it's been online I have a bookmark of
like you know certain trailers and it's
been on this do a popular vote if you
will it's a popular vote let it cool
no any election II know as we film this
don't know if Trump is president yet
he's currently in the lead at times
videos up I'm sure that we'll know
depart the president I gotta go to bed
and by the time I wake up like that'll
be my first thought of the day my is is
president someone will be President a
dogs purpose so a dog's purpose Donald
Trump story that's pretty good
ambolyn that's Stevens feel the meaning
of life are we here for a reason is
there a point to any of this
and why does fruity so much better in
the car this was me and then this was me
then I came back as this little guy a
lot of lives for one not to live but I'm
getting ahead of myself
let's start at the beginning so for me
it all began with a boy his name was
Ethan Bailey behave and girls
my name was Bailey Bailey Bailey Bailey
Oh Bailey do it listen for me
whatever words got Ethan down I knew
exactly what to do right I'm ready
now played with that ball all afternoon
Ethan loved it
sometimes he just needed a little nudge
sorry that was the dog with me
damn whoa should teach your dog some man
hurt we spent every day together they
fighting over food
mmm nothing in there as the years went
by I could tell my time ivy thing was
coming to an end
good boy do I miss you and then it
happened I was back I didn't have it I'm
a girl good girl good wall I had a new
purpose I was needed again ah he doesn't
have his dick and again and again Wow
I was learning a new lesson don't
reincarnation for hair did you find that
okay ready Dennis Quaid
my god I tried to make sense out of all
the things I'd see was there a point to
this journey of mine and how did they
can fit in oh they can always fit
if I can get you licking and loving I
have my purpose
maybe was of his dog with you it's like
a girl found replacement dogs laughing
at you dogs don't laugh that's funny
wow wow that looks enjoyable yeah that
looks cute in my cart wormy that looks
really enjoyable
it really does like I think we are both
smiling the whole time I love dogs cute
I love dogs did you know that dogs I
watched on a National Geographic
documentary dogs they release oxytocin
yeah when you bond with them because of
the level of love it also you know what
am i I forgot all these facts actual
antenna that that's trying to remember
they heard that it reduces the risk of
heart disease and on average dogs help
increase your life by at least 10 years
and there's their therapy yeah exactly
this where all this is linking back to I
need a dog I don't have one I need one
yeah you should I think you should
totally get a dog I need one maybe after
the new year yeah yeah yeah yeah that
was good though there's such a deeper
meaning yeah it's cool because dogs do
live a short amount of time
yeah I love dogs is they just like get
around a good dogs you know it's like
there are some there's some dogs you
were just comments yeah who don't want
your attention their dogs or just barky
you or run away from you and their dogs
you just love everyone yeah if I get a
dog I want my dog to be really nice yeah
but not just like freak out and start
loving a human being a human being my
next-door neighbor Tony his girlfriend
Courtney the rep I've got three got
three dogs who just like love you Azir
they do they do
you're very human being Alan [ __ ]
[ __ ] love me won't you blow into
a lot gotta have that trust you gotta
have like you gotta earn this dog trust
a little bit but he's not he's not a
like a mean [ __ ] it's almost
like some people when their dogs get
around people they're like wow he
doesn't usually do that I want a dog
like that where I can feel like I kind
of trust you more as my dog it takes it
like an elective this dog chooses no
chooses can tell good a man yeah have a
son yeah exactly
I'm serious they know I'm being serious
too no why do you think we have
watchdogs and all that you know cuz
they're smart they're smart they know
and the fact that it was such a short
amount of time it's cool that they're
saying like there's their lives to live
on though their spirit still lives on
because they're you come back
reincarnated yeah that's really kind
that's really awesome you have to put
your time away to look at like when yeah
when you lose a dog it's very sad it's
really heartbreaking but if you choose
to get another one you can form that
bond again yeah I need someone who felt
like her best friend growing up was her
dog yeah because she didn't have friends
in school that many friends in school
and then she never guys say goodbye to
the dog oh there wasn't then they had to
put the dog down though because she was
she was gone
it still bothered her it was like ten
years later she would still like cry a
lot better so I feel like yeah dogs are
they have a huge impact we're getting so
we are so like the video about dogs dogs
proof is moving without like how we feel
about dogs but they never getting really
savvy about it yeah I just wonder if the
human stories are actually gonna be
interesting you know like all the
stories where they're seeing this guy go
right one falls in love with this girl I
don't know what all the stories are but
you know he clearly developed several
kind of relationships and what I just
hope those URLs as interesting as listen
to the dogs are a lot a lot yeah
obviously yeah you can't bring much from
that to carry the whole entire exactly
oh those are strong I wish we did acting
scenes in class with dogs
how cool would that be we can't we just
said why can we just gotta ask our
teachers yeah bring a dog to class it's
not range of movies are you gonna try to
active the thing well guys if you're new
to the channel and you can subscribe
today Lisa's on Instagram Lisa and Malik
it's true good there's photos that
you'll enjoy because why not I don't
know that was very that made me sound
intriguing thank you all the dogs
watching this channel